los bomberos trabajan contrarreloj para
cortar el paso al fuego en la región del
gigante en el sur de francia a más de
14.000 personas han sido evacuadas y ya
son miles las hectáreas calcinadas
tenemos dos grandes incendios que
comenzaron casi al mismo tiempo
así que tuvimos que encontrar los
recursos que teníamos en el departamento
de gijón para poder intervenir muy
rápido ante algo rápido nosotros acá
somos también españa y portugal han
estado azulados por el fuego
consecuencia de una ola de calor con
termómetros por encima de los 45 grados
este pueblo de extremadura al oeste de
españa celebraba sus fiestas locales
fueron canceladas ante los fuertes
fuegos que rondan a la población estamos
muy nerviosos todos pero no te voy a
decir todo lo que eso lleva acabo de
bajar que vivo allí ahí en esa terraza y
ahí me venía me baja porque parecía que
venían amigos
extremadura ha sido la región más
golpeada y sus habitantes aquejan los
cambios en el clima el cambio climático
al final tiene que ver pero el mundo
entero y esto que una zona verde fresca
en verano se está poniendo pues como
oliver sur de badajoz córdoba y sevilla
otros lugares también se han visto
afectados como málaga en el sur o
barcelona- en el norte incluso en la
norteña galicia conocida por sus
frecuentes lluvias los bomberos
enfrentan 12 incendios aunque la agencia
meteorológica española dijo que la ola
de calor terminaría el lunes advirtió
que las temperaturas seguirán siendo
anormalmente altas entretanto en
portugal el gobierno rebajó el estado de
contingencia a alerta tras días de
intenso trabajo contra el fuego pero aún
900 efectivos siguen en el combate de
cuatro incendios activos